it is the world's highest court formed
in the aftermath of the Second World War
to end state abuses of power
Myanmar stands accused of perhaps the
greatest abuse the genocide of its own
people
last month its civilian leader Aung San
su Chi wants a human rights icon
arrived at the International Court of
Justice to contest the claims the case
against her government was brought by
the Gambia on behalf of dozens of Muslim
countries in action means that more
people have been killed more women
I've been Ravi and more children have
been burned alive the court heard
allegations of atrocity after atrocity
Myanmar's military is accused of mass
murder rape and the destruction of Ranga
Muslim communities the Nobel Peace Prize
laureate watched on a woman detained for
years by Myanmar's military now
defending them she doesn't have control
over the army but sue Chi's personally
accused of failing to hold it to account
she called for the case to be dropped
near my requests a court to remove the
case from its list Gama says the raids
of Ranga villages in Rakhine State in
2017 were legitimate counterterrorism
operations a response to attacks by
armed rahaga
on government security posts three years
on more than 700,000 Ranga refugees
languishing camps across the border in
Bangladesh the Gambia believes Myanmar's
trying to wipe out an entire ethnic
group the court could take many years to
reach a final ruling on genocide the
type of evidence that is needed to prove
genocide is quite burdensome for
applicants states like the Gambia but
it's also because the legal test that's
needed to be met by the applicant state
is also quite high so the applicant the
Gambia will have to show that there was
specific intent to commit genocide on
Thursday the ICJ will say whether or not
it has granted an emergency ruling known
as provisional measures to prevent
further acts of serious violence
including murder rape the burning down
of villages the prevention of access
medicine one thing the court cannot do
though is enforce its rulings in the
past
some countries have simply ignored them
this is not a criminal case charges
won't be brought against individuals
that may come later at a different court
nevertheless ank's and Suchi finds
herself together with me a man's
military the focus of serious
allegations accused of complicity in
some of the world's worst crimes Nev
Barca al Jazeera The Hague